rogers eat it pete
reportedly not expected to attend
packers mandatory minicamp barring some
sort of change just enough weasel words
in there i don't mean that in a
pejorative way although i don't know
when you ever use weasel words in a
non-pejorative way but there's just
enough of a safe harbor in the report
from nfl media ex expect it to not show
up barring a change of heart look i
think aaron rodgers likes this mystery
the beautiful mystery he wants people
talking about him and then he wants to
be able to say why are you talking about
me that's the way it is reminds me of
when elaine had the botticelli shoes she
liked it because everybody was talking
about him and they wanted to know where
she got him and she got pissed off when
people were talking about her shoes and
wanted to know where she got him that's
aaron rodgers in a nutshell he wants us
all talking about him and he wants to be
upset that we're all talking about him
so it ca it can't be a clean answer
right chris it's got to be not expected
to attend barring some sort of a change
of heart so we'll keep paying attention
oh is he going to show up he's not
expected to maybe he will maybe he won't
let's see so i don't know i i guess he's
not going to and the cheeseheads are
going to lose their minds yeah i mean
yeah i don't expect them to show i don't
i mean why would anybody else that
really expect him i mean with the way
this off season's gone i i just i don't
see it you know i just think with aaron
rodgers but i love my teammates i love
the coaches i love the fans like at some
point suck it up i was telling rich
eisen yesterday we all got a problem
with the boss at some level not us of
course but i mean you know people show
up for work every day and they don't
like the boss but i like my co-workers i
like what i do yeah i got issues with
management they haven't given me a raise
in 15 months and i need more money and i
want this i like where my office is and
but i i love my workplace yeah so i i
just think it shows that all that
stuff's bs well i i don't i'm not gonna
buy that i'm not gonna say that it's bs
i think it's real you know because like
what you said there too to your point is
like okay yeah you know i love my job i
love all those things yeah we all have
our problems with our boss but you know
i think he feels like the boss has lied
to him the bosses have been trying to
replace him behind his back or trying to
push him out the door
so yeah he doesn't love the bosses at
all and he is uncomfortable i think in a
totality as far as being there in green
bay about where he is and where's his
place in the organization for the next
few years i can understand that i have
sympathy for that without a doubt i
understand i get frustrated with the
cryptic part of all of this at times too
but i think this is real too i don't
think this is one where i could just you
know you know like we all like i say
swipe it under the rug and just be like
oh that's all right no big deal i'll
forget about it i think there's a lot of
circumstances that have gone on here
that have led him to have a chat butt
and he's going to just kind of wait this
out and let like the storm
fizzle a little bit so he could go to
training camp and make that first day
to answer some questions and then he
won't be available for three or four
weeks and he's hoping like it all just
kind of melts and fades away
but do we think
that this is a precursor to him not
showing up for training camp if you're
going to show up for training camp why
not be there for the mandatory mini camp
why are you skipping that because i
think he just looks at it like this is
not a necessity for
them to necessarily be a great team or
do anything like that i think he can he
could swallow the pill of okay i'm going
to miss three days of mandatory mini
camp i'm going to miss a few meetings
some seven on seven sessions and some
routes with air all right well i'll make
up for that in july when i get the
receivers to my house or whatever else
and we throw the footballs then i i
would be shocked like where where i'm
i'd be more i'd be shocked today to see
him at mandatory mini camp but i also
will be even more shocked if he pulls
this kind of shenanigans for training
camp when that comes because i i do
i do think that that's a time where yeah
the scrutiny will get real he will have
a fan base that will start to get pissed
at him you will start to filter into the
locker room and the coaches once you get
into training camp and now you're
missing and you're messing with the team
and you're messing with the year that's
when like the stuff that you talk about
i think you get very real for rogers to
where he can feel that pressure and
that's where he's definitely gonna be
there at least in my thought
cumulative fine of 93 085 dollars under
the cba if aaron rodgers misses all
three days the mandatory mini camp
that's the number that applies to any
player under contract who misses all
three days of the annual mandatory mini
camp he's already given up 500 000
in a workout bonus because he needed to
be present for 85
of the offseason program to get that
that was gone by the time he landed in
hawaii so
no 500 000 the 93 000. now the
difference is that's money out of your
pocket yes it's one thing to say i can
earn 500 000 and i choose not to it's
another thing to have to write a check
or have money deducted from that's how
they're doing game checks right and and
the packers
have not decided whether or not
to find him that could be yeah an olive
branch but look i don't know how
interested they are in extending olive
branches i go back to mark murphy's
gratuitous
right turn
in responding to a fan question that
didn't even ask about aaron rodgers when
he says the aaron rodgers situation has
divided our fan base and we've decided
not to say anything publicly about it
you know except the fact that it's
divided our fan base and uh i i don't
know are they inclined to do this guy
any favors he's
technically in violation of his contract
by not showing up to mandatory mini camp
technically now he's got a broader
contract with the
union and the league under the cba that
allows him to not show up if he's
willing to pay the 93 grand but
yeah it i don't know i don't know who
makes that call
as to whether or not they find him but i
assume mark murphy is far more involved
in these decisions than anyone realized
i would think so i think that is a kind
of a mark murphy you know president of
football operations gm conversation type
of decision there on what to do and i
mean you're right the 500 000 workout
bonus okay yes that was you you had to
earn that this is one where again it's
93 000 we know that's a lot of damn
money but
for a guy like aaron rodgers it's not
something like you said he doesn't have
to write a check it's oh the week one
check you get aaron rodgers that is for
2 million will now be for you know
190 you know 90 000 or 900 000 instead
that's where it's going to be different
so that's not going to make or break
aaron rogers or nor is he going to care
but i think like at least in my
experience in these type of cases where
it's
not just a mid-level player trying to
make a point or something like this star
players the star player
more times than not they don't get fined
in these situations by their football
team and
i would think that this is one that
green bay is probably going to be
careful about not to ruffle his feathers
a little bit more
and i i don't think we'll really get the
answer to this until training camp right
whether they really want to take or make
that we don't know when do we know go
ahead yeah tell me here's the thing yeah
under the cba that was
newly to by the league in the union last
year right
fifty thousand dollars per day for
skipping training camp
must be paid that must cannot that's
right
right now i look you can always find
ways to legitimately funnel money back
to a guy you can just give him a raise
at the end of the year or during the
year for the two million dollars that he
lost in fines for staying away from
training camp but it's not as clean and
easy as it used to be
when you just say okay fine you held out
you came back we're not gonna we're not
gonna charge you this money they have to
charge aaron rodgers and now he doesn't
care about 50 000 a day either this is
about proven his point and and maybe he
look chris
maybe he really is
willing
to
sit out willing to not either be
prepared for the season or not show up
for the season maybe he's sufficiently
pissed at the green bay packers
organization the corporation not the
coaches not the teammates but the the
the structure
of the of the team of the franchise that
he he isn't going to show up and i still
think that
that look look what's what's going to
happen this week jordan love
yeah we're going to get more reps it's a
starting quarterback right let's get him
ready i i still think that if i'm mark
murphy this guy's been a pain in my ass
for years now especially behind the
scenes all the stuff we don't know about
hey
he doesn't want to be here fine we'll
take 35 million out of his pockets or
it's a combination of taking money back
and not paying him 14.7 million salary
and 6.8 million roster bonus that he's
earned but he gets week by week during
the season but by the time you take
signing bonus and not pay all the other
stuff it is over 30 million dollars
we'll take that we'll reinvest it we'll
get jordan love ready he'll be the bad
guy because he didn't show up we're
constantly saying we want him here we
love aaron rodgers we we want him back
he's our guy he's our guy
and uh you know expectations are reduced
this year
isn't a great year for us unless jordan
love ends up being great right out of
the gates and then 2022 we trade aaron
rodgers for maximum compensation and we
move forward i i just
i don't know that that's that bad of an
outcome when the alternative is to give
in to aaron rodgers and abandon your
plan to develop jordan love as a
successor well okay i mean you don't
have to give in i mean they're not
giving in right now right what's he want
yeah
so if the alternative is giving in okay
yeah fine stay away give us 35 million
let us get jordan love ready we'll trade
you for multiple first round picks plus
in march and we move forward and jordan
love is another year more prepared by
the time 2022 rolls around my point is
that's door number one we don't know
what door number two is no we don't
still don't know exactly what he wants
we he wants brian guticun's fired and
he's never rebutted that well that's a
non-starter so i i just i don't know
what it takes at this point we know he
wants commitment we know that we know i
mean but i think it's too late for that
it might be i got a feeling i got a
feeling he gave him a chance to do it
right and now he wants more than that
yeah listen i understand like you know
your hard ball scenario with that and
like not wanting to bend or do something
like that and do something drastic to
where
yeah it ruins your plans for the next
two or three years because you've been
to you know like you're saying some guy
that's been a pain in a butt or a thorn
in her side or whatever that is but
but at the same time it's still a
delicate matter here and i gotta think
they gotta be a little worried about you
know
have an egg on their face here with this
situation too so it it it is aaron
rodgers he is the leader of the football
team he's the best player on the
football team and he's the reason we
talk about you being in the super bowl
window you know when you do things and
treat a guy like that it goes
you know
it it permeates throughout the locker
room that people will feel those shock
waves whoa that's how they treat the
best player the star those things that
so these are all things that you know
mark murphy and them have to
be you know realizing that could happen
here if they want to play this hardball
game with rogers and never bend let
alone again
you know they're they're playing the
risk of yeah all right do we really want
to tell rogers you know screw off we're
not bending or doing anything in your
favor here
and
roll the dice with jordan love i think
that's got to be a scary thing too now
you know yes people might not like aaron
rodgers but if green bay like we talked
about yesterday starts jordan love and
they go 6 and 11 and it looks shaky
well there's only going to be one person
that the green bay fans are going to be
pissed at after that they're going to go
what we we did this for this
and that's to me where you know rogers
does have a little power and i think he
knows that i think he knows that guten
kust and murphy just don't think this
guy's ready yet and that's where he has
a little bit power in his own corner
there
but they had to have known they knew or
should have known that this is the path
that they were embarking on i know when
they created up
to draft jordan love they saw something
in their pre-draft study and they would
privately say well it wasn't like
a
a master plan like the chiefs had to go
get patrick mahomes right this just kind
of unhappy right on draft night right we
wanted justin jefferson vikings got him
we wanted brandon ayuk up 49ers traded
up to 25 to get him well they scrambled
i don't know whether they panicked i
mean either way it's not a good look no
either that's right either they already
had a float chart where it was like all
right justin jefferson then brandon ayuk
then
jordan love or they freaked out when the
49ers went from 31 to 25 and decided oh
crap we better go from 30 to 26 to get
this quarterback that we want if the two
receivers we covered aren't there i i
can't believe that's what it's weird
out of their butts right the night of
the draft they had to have known that
this was on the radar screen because you
think through all the options that's why
the teams do mock drafts what happens if
these are the first 29 what if these are
the first 29 what if these are the first
29 what's our option what's our option
what's our option
and their third option was go get jordan
love so i look at it this way and and
i've said this before
the fact that they could have used the
30th overall pick and the fourth round
pick they packaged to go get jordan love
on two different players who could have
helped them
beat the buccaneers beat the chiefs win
the super bowl the fact that they got
jordan love instead should at some level
make them more determined
to prove that he's the right guy
to prove that they did the right thing
sure to prove that he can be a franchise
quarterback in the successor to aaron
rodgers but i mean i i think you're
right the problem is there
is
the coaches i don't think we're involved
in this and they have nothing to prove
that's the other part of this so the
front office did this on their own by
all accounts i think you and i have
heard enough to think that that's what
went down at least that the the coaches
weren't like hey let's it's time to
think about replacing rogers let's trade
up and it was not a coach's decision so
they're not all in on this and so
they're not invested in this either so
and and of course they're invested into
wait we want to win games so we can keep
our job oh that's right that guy number
12 does best in that so let's keep him
around hey that's aaron rodgers he's the
heart and soul of our team i hope he's
back that's right because that's how
they feel and like the way you explain
the draft and everything like that
either way it's just not an acceptable
answer you know oh you wanted the
receivers they weren't there
so wait we decided to drive
trade up to get a quarterback the
receivers weren't there i mean that's
where i just don't understand it i mean
and then of course there was other good
receivers on the board
still if they just stayed where they
were i mean t higgins is pretty good
michael pittman jr is pretty good chase
claypool pretty good i mean so that's
where it doesn't even make sense that
way to me
uh from a football standpoint let alone
the way they handled it and all of those
type of things and i i don't know it's
it's it's crazy right it's crazy
situation
down right gotten extra lottery tickets
and even more players who could have
potentially helped the team right get
past the buccaneers and beat the chiefs
if they had beaten the buccaneers in the
nfc championship game look i
i
there has been
within the packers organization for
several years now
an element of dysfunction
and i don't know who's to blame for it i
don't know
the one constant well two constants yeah
has been aaron rodgers and mark murphy
that's right
and and chris
let me remind everyone of this
after tyler dunn
published and at the time he was with
bleacher that's right yep he's now got
his own thing i think it's go long i
think so tyler's a good guy
i mean yeah i know him great guy he's
there yep
long
article delving into the relationship
between rogers and mike mccarthy who at
the time had been fired and everyone was
trying to figure out what went wrong
great article a lot of stuff in there
and one of the things that mark murphy
said i think it was even a quote in the
article or in the aftermath of the
article he was kind of happy he thought
hey you know if this
gets some people around here pissed off
that may be good for us and that always
stuck with me because
i think at some level he's the mad
scientist stirring the pot
thinking that hey if this jordan love
thing gets aaron rodgers a little more
pissed off maybe that's going to be good
for us and i just think that you can
only push the buttons and pull the
strings of a guy like aaron rodgers for
so long before he figures out he's being
manipulated before he figures out right
you're concocting reasons to get him
upset and he's going to turn that on you
not on the circumstance he's going to
turn it on you and say screw you and i
think that's one of the reasons why this
is blown up in their faces and and at
some level you know we've said why are
they treating aaron rodgers like this
he's never been
wishy-washy he's never done the brett
favre will i or won't i retire he's
never held the franchise hostage that
way no but he's been a chronic pain in
their ass yes behind the scenes sure and
at a certain point you've had enough of
that too yeah i mean i listen i i get it
you know i mean most star players are a
little bit of a pain in the butt there's
no doubt and rogers yeah i mean i think
rogers has
felt
somewhat at least on the outside looking
in if i'm him disrespected probably for
a number of years
i i just look at it that way you know i
mean yeah
between
you know some of the offense
that he's been involved in you know lack
of creativity you know i was saying that
a few years ago i mean the offense it
was a fifth grade offense you know the
other good teams in football were you
know in advanced geometry and there was
aaron rodgers running slant flat and
double slant and oh rare and they know
we're running but just throw a rifle in
there and just get it in there oh okay
coach no problem i mean so he feels that
way they've never gone all in on them in
any capacity really
any angle i mean i mean damn we almost
broke the internet when they free agency
they signed zadarius smith and preston
smith holy crap we've never seen them do
that i mean all those things i think
through the years probably have piled up
on him and then there he goes wait
you've done nothing but i keep us in the
playoff hunt and super bowl relevant
every year i take a nice contract yeah
i'm a pain in the butt and i've
complained but then all of a sudden you
do this and i think that's where it just
all came to a head to where he's like
wait they didn't tell me i had no idea i
was still playing good they traded up we
were just in the nfc championship game
we wasted it on that i think all of
those things it's just all funneled to
this point in this situation to where
he's pissed but i will say i just would
be absolutely shocked if he still missed
training camp i just think because of
all the things we've talked about and
how hyper aware he is and everything and
i just can't imagine him giving up a
year of football
right now with as good as he's playing
and still knowing that this team is
damn good it's that great but it's damn
good
one other factor and i'm reluctant to
mention it but
it's something that i know
the packers
are considering are factoring into their
overall thought process
look
he's got a fiance
she's got influence i'm not even going
to try to pronounce her first name she
shows him shayleen is it shayleen woody
shayleen or shylane i think it's shaylee
i've been saying for a long time but i'm
either way if i'm wrong well well-known
actress not nearly well-known enough by
us to get her first name right by that
but but
look
the the the the the partner
has say as of saying no doubt
and and again is that right is that
right no it doesn't matter partner has a
set that's right and i'm not putting any
blame on anybody i'm just saying that's
a wild card in the relationship that is
still fairly new for the packers to have
to deal with
and if she's all in
with screw them and i can't believe they
did do what they did to you and put you
through that with this jordan love thing
and didn't even bother to give you a
phone call i mean if she's all in with
the
yes you should be upset and you
shouldn't go and oh by the way i got
plenty of money too so we don't got to
worry about you not playing football for
a year if she's all in with that it's
more likely to go one way if she's
saying do you really want to have you
really thought this through i mean
haven't we all been there at some point
definitely the spouse i've been married
almost 27 years right
are you re have you really thought this
through you know i mean when you start
getting questions like that's like maybe
you're right yeah jaylene yes shaylene
thank you pete no you're so you're right
that's but i know the packers are like
you know we don't know is that gonna
is that gonna
be well maybe it already is and maybe
it's gonna be a factor when the time
comes to show up for training camp well
you always gotta take you know the the
the misses the significant other the
wife you know into into you know account
there's no doubt that's they're part of
the situat the situation the problem
solving i certainly never made like a
decision in my career without talking
about it with my wife and letting her
know so she could let me know her
feelings about wanting to live there do
anything like that i mean it is it is
part of the game hey my dad here's a
funny story he was he was thinking about
signing with the cleveland browns and
bill belichick he told my mom you know
maybe you should start looking for high
schools in cleveland and everything for
christopher and the schools and the kids
and my mom said oh no honey
we'll we'll just come and see the home
games and then you know we'll just see
you you can come home in the bye week
and that was kind of the that was kind
of the end of the cleveland discussion i
mean i think
whoa okay wait so you guys aren't going
to move out there with me all right and
you know i think that did he still went
out there for a visit but it was
something in the back of his mind where
he was like i don't know if i'm gonna do
this or not so that is a real situation
uh but hopefully she can realize too
at the end i think this is a thing where
if he sits out a year he's going to look
back at this in 10 years from now in his
life and go i shouldn't have done that
i'm mad i did that i was playing too
good a football and i shouldn't have
wasted that year of my last few five or
six years of my career you know wasting
it away because they screwed me over uh
and and i i always come back to that
thought too
peter king made the suggestion here on
friday and reduced it to writing and
football morning in america that the two
sides should come together and agree
that aaron rodgers will play one more
year for the packers and they'll trade
him after the season i think it's a
great idea i think it makes a ton of
sense i think it's very logical i just
have a feeling it's four months too late
i just think that it's too late that
that bridge is going to take more
more repair work than to say
we'll trade you after the season because
i think aaron would sit and say were you
going to trade me anyway after the
season i'm not stupid i'm not stupid
i'll make you trade me next year i'll
sit out all of this year and i'll just
show up at a time when you've moved on
and of course you're gonna trade me at
that point so i i i just think that
this this game of four-dimensional chess
is not going to be easily won by the
packers at this point especially because
i
you know look i think staying away from
the mandatory minute camp is is
as significant as staying away from
training camp because when have we seen
a franchise quarterback
ever not show up for the mandatory mini
camp when's that ever happened franchise
quarterbacks show up for off-season
workouts all the time russell wilson as
unhappy as he is right with the seattle
seahawks he's there with bell's on
getting ready setting aside his personal
feelings and recognizing i got a legacy
on the line i got to get ready for the
season i'm there they got their
mandatory mini camp next year he's there
for a week of otas before the mandatory
mini camp so there's still a competitive
element to this definitely it gets
undermined
and uh uh you know aaron rodgers
sabotaging himself and indirectly the
chain by not being there and being
prepared so i think it's secret it's
extremely significant it is it is you're
i'm not gonna like you know downplay it
i'm not but i don't think it's it's not
training camp significant i will say
that that there is a difference but for
yes a franchise quarterback these type
of players like rogers brady's whatever
the mahomes the josh allen's they're
they're there
any chance they can get they're always
around the facility oh it's mini camp
it's otas i didn't know i'm here i mean
i came to work all right that's just the
way those guys are wired so it is not
within like his his natural way to want
to stay away from this type of thing but
unlike the russell
wilson situation you know russell wilson
wasn't secretly you know being planned
against behind closed doors to be
replaced and then not being told about
anything or anything like that after he
brought them to the nfc championship
game and that to me is just when you lay
it out like that i mean gosh it sounds
weird coming out of your mouth it sounds
weird when i say it i go
did i say that right did i say that
right wait a guy who was like 26
and 4
13 and 3
nfc championship game without a doubt
one of the five best players in football
they didn't tell them they were going to
draft a quarterback and they tried to
replace him that's it's insane so we
could say yeah when is a franchise
quarterback ever done
you know missed a mini camp i could also
go when the hell have we ever seen a
franchise do this to a quarterback to
the stature of aaron rodgers so it goes
both ways here for sure
plenty of blame to go around that's for
damn sure and here's the other side of
it too chris
rogers isn't there to face the music
from the media so
everybody else is going to have to i've
made that point before yeah i know at a
certain point the teammates will start
rolling their eyes privately among
themselves what the hell
yeah i gotta go i gotta go do this zoom
thing
yeah my turn
god how about what's the over under on
questions i'm gonna get about about
aaron oh three and a half well i got
five of them you know i i they're gonna
ask about aaron because he's not there
to speak for himself so others are gonna
have to speak for him and um
you know again we can blame the team we
can blame aaron rodgers ultimately you
blame the circumstance quarterback not
there and the others who are there
trying to get ready for the season have
to deal with all the questions that's
another part of this too now i don't
know what kind of gift baskets or or
handwritten notes or text messages aaron
rodgers has sent to his teammates to get
them to feel good about carrying this
burden but they're going to have to
carry it because he didn't show up to
carry it himself yeah they're going to
have to deal with jobs weekend that's
for sure you're right now it will like
to your point
it will wear on the team and the players
if we get in the training camp and now
it's like a weekend and he hasn't been
there that's where players are starting
to go oh here we go i'm going to press
conference right nobody really wants to
talk about me i'm going to have to talk
about the quarterback okay i have to
talk about that situation let me be
careful about what i say let me make
sure i don't piss off the coaches of the
front office well that wears on players
for sure and rogers will be i think
aware of that too
think of the stress that it introduces
for the player who is asked
on one hand about aaron rodgers
on the other hand about jordan love but
is aaron going to be mad at me because i
said all those good things about jordan
love well what if jordan loves going to
be my quarterback this year he's doing
well i got to say he's doing well i want
him to like me too yeah i mean the
players on offense the guys who have to
run the pass routes and catch the
football right and rely upon the
quarterback to distribute the football
to them
they're going to be caught in a hell of
a dilemma chris as a practical matter
well who's asked do i kiss harder here
yeah well they know they know to kiss
the ass of the king and that's number
12. okay so the king but but you're
right they gotta they gotta be careful
we've already seen guys like aaron jones
yes that's where i was going raise
jordan exactly and that's how they'll
praise him right he's so much more
comfortable right it's not gonna be
about like whoa
look at what he's doing he's out here
throwing lasers because that would be
like a challenge to rogers it's going to
be more about like he's so much more
comfortable he's more confident in the
offense he knows where he's going with
the ball those are the praises the type
of praise you're gonna hear from jordan
love they'll know not to cross over to
go man he looks amazing out here our
offense hasn't missed a beat and jordan
love is throwing just dimes that's where
they know they're gonna have to you know
make sure they don't
piss off the king uh by saying stuff
like that
so when the question is how does jordan
love compare to aaron rodgers the answer
will be i'm sorry i didn't hear the
question can you repeat it how does
jordan love compare to aaron rodgers i'm
sorry i didn't hear the question can you
repeat it and just keep saying that over
and over again until they move on what
that that will be the strategy well or
you're just you're just going to go well
come on you know you say something like
what is that rogers is you know the nfl
mvp jordan love is doing some really
good things out here and we're excited
about what we see but you know let's
pump the brakes before we start
comparing them to aaron rodgers or
something like that they could say that
and that would be a nice compliment
about jordan love it's not disrespecting
rogers and you're also you know not not
lying or bullcrap in that way either
here's the bottom line yeah
the green bay packers corporation is
going to continue to thrive it thrived
through 20 years of
sh-t football from 72 to 92. they still
filled up lambeau field they still had a
waiting list longer than most people's
lifetimes they will get past this the
green bay packers will endure the cheese
heads will not go rotten this is the way
it is and at some point they were bound
to separate from aaron rodgers so mark
murphy who's been entrusted with the
keys to the franchise i just think at
some point you say it's in the best
interest of the team to move on from
this guy who has been a low-key cancer
for the past few years on what we're
trying to do because we run the team we
manage the team the players play he has
thought that he has transcended that and
maybe other quarterbacks in other cities
have but they haven't done it here and
we're not letting him do it here and if
he doesn't see that then he doesn't
belong here and i think it just makes it
easier to justify the hard line and the
secret hope that he doesn't show up i
know we've done everything but you know
like i can't be five million i already
won't show up it's not on us know you're
right but see i can't get behind some of
that stuff there like yeah he's a pain
in the butt but he hasn't gotten
involved he doesn't complain when they
never draft anybody on offense or never
sign anybody in free agency we don't
know that no we don't know that okay he
hasn't done it publicly
usually if he is pissed off about stuff
like that there's something cryptic said
or something he didn't do that so that's
also more reason to where he just
feels cheated been cheated in my opinion
and all of those things and and that's
where it's uh a crazy situation but i'm
looking at it from the perspective of
the packers yeah all the decisions
and their attitude that led them to this
point yeah i get it they're looking at
it that way the next natural step is
screw this guy yeah we've had enough
right and and and there's an easy way to
do this we know we're going to trade him
next march we don't have to tell anybody
that we're not upset publicly we're
going to trade him in march but for now
if you don't want to show up fine don't
show up be the bad guy on the way out
the door give us back 35 million dollars
let us say well hey you know jordan love
but
we didn't get much
chance last year so folks don't expect
much the bar needs to be six and 11 for
this team but this is an investment in
the future and if you're not happy with
the fact that we're six and 11 number 12
is the one to go talk to because he's
under contract for this year he's
breaching that contract by not showing
up that i just think that
regardless of whether we agree with that
position that's to me the next logical
step
in what we've seen the packers already
do if they don't want to give more or
they just yeah if rogers is asking for
more
uh and wants something in return i
understand that position i i i mean i
get it i do it's risky like we mentioned
but i just think rogers is too smart and
aware and he's i mean 35 million dollars
is still 35 million dollars i just can't
imagine him giving that up along with
all the other football stuff we've
talked about
hey it's better for us
if he shows up
it's better for us
if he's upset
and everything he says this year can be
analyzed for whatever the message is to
brian gooda koontz mark murphy or
someone else in the organization i mean
that will be high drama that will be
borderline shakespearean if he shows up
uh so i hope he does oh of course i mean
i want him there i want him to get i'm
one of the for all the sound bites and
of course i want to see him throwing
lasers around the field i hope he's
pissed off and throwing balls everywhere
so that's that's that's the best aaron
rodgers like we saw last year so i'm
excited for that it'll be a better
football season if he's playing yes and
then the ultimate outcome yeah
paul crew
and the warden go pick up the football
or the lombardi trophy and
shove it into the midsection of mark
murphy and say stick this in your trophy
case and walk off into the sunset so i i
that would be the ultimate
capper to this if roger shows up so
that's that's what we're that's what
we're rooting for that's what rooting
for we want him to show up but for this
week
barring something unforeseen he's not
expected to show up and we'll see if
that unforeseen thing happened
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports